parer maintenant sur l'affaire people du
moment Bruno Vandelli vous rappelez le
chorégraphe bien sûr Bruno Vandelli qui
avait fait pop St notamment accusé de
viol par Yanis Marchall le point sur les
nouveaux éléments et ce weekend l'ex
professeur de la starac donc Yanis
Marchall s'est exprimé sur BFM TV
regardez ma mère m'a amené chez Bruno
vendelli il m'a de suite adoré en danse
très très vite il y a eu un
rapprochement de sa part un jour il me
chorégraphie en solo lui demande si je
peux récupérer la musique dit oui souci
et donc après il m'amène chez lui il me
demande si j'ai
vu un concert de Janet Jackson j'avais
pas vu le concert lui il avait donc il
me dit bah viens viens j'ai une télé
dans la chambre et on va regarder le
concert donc il met le concert il se met
à côté de moi et et moi je j'ai les gens
qui commencent à trembler je comme si
l'instinct comme si je sentais que il y
avait ça commença à être bizarre et de
là voilàf sans rentrer dans les détails
il m'a fait ce qu'il m'a fait il raconte
que tout cela s'est passé alors qu'il
avait seulement 13 14 ans ou il était
très jeune il parle d'agression sexuelle
alors il faut savoir que Maître Cohen
Saban qui était sur ce plateau vendredi
avocat de Bruno Vandelli nous a expliqué
qu'il n'avait pas reçu la plainte de
Yanis Marchall voilà et Bruno Vandelli a
porter plainte lui aussi al il y a
Lionel team qui est là qui est qui
s'occupe du public qui s'occupe très
bien du public lonel qui veut réagir
alors tu sais qu' va on va on va on va
on on va regarder l'extrédianis et
apparemment
lionelonel toi on peut lu j'ai des infos
en fait pourquoi tu les connais je les
connais très très bien les deux tu as
fait popst c'est vrai ouais j'ai fait
popstar et puis j'étais aussi le petit
ami de la colocatrice de Bruno ah ouais
B alors on regarde l'extrait tu nous en
parles viens te mettre à côté deam PAL
t'inquiète pas le morp elle est très
sympa regarde
vas-y j'ai pris un moment en fait avant
de réaliser tout ce qui m'était arrivé
ça prend des années et c'est vraiment 10
ans plus tard que c'est un peu venu et
que j'ai pu pointer le doigt un peu sur
bah en fait remett pointer le doigt sur
lui j'avais déjà le envie d'en parler de
faire quelque chose parce que surtout
j'ai toujours entendu parler d'histoire
qui continuaient à l'école de danse
n'importe quelle personne qui est dans
le milieu de la danse qui connaît Bruno
Vandelli c'est que il y a aucune
surprise aujourd'hui aucune alors c'est
incroyable Lionel merci en tout cas de
de prendre la parole ce soir franchement
c'est c'est fort Lionel donc en fait toi
tu étais dans les bah tu faisais partie
des Ling Cup oui c'est ça popst avec mat
poora et Otis c'était l'année d'après
après les wat for donc le j Bro Vell
était jury du du concours ou et bah en
fait au début de ma carrière je faisais
des plateau télé puis un jour je tombe
amoureux d'une d'une danseuse des ballet
de Bruno Vandelli et bah commence une
romance ou qui a duré assez longtemps et
en fait je vivais avec cette filleel et
ben le colocataire de cette fillel
c'était Bruno Vandelli donc en gros
aujourd'hui si je suis sur le plateau
c'est parce qu'en fait je veux juste
remettre les choses au clair c'est c'est
très fort par tu tu connais très bien
les deux tu connaissais tu connaissais
bien Yanis aussi alors connaissis Yanis
en fait la première fois que j'ai
rencontré Yanis c'était dans
l'appartement de cette jeune fille en
2005 2005 donc ça donc 2005 c'était
c'était en 2005 donc j'étais dans
l'appartement je rencontre pour la
première fois de ma vie Yan donc on est
en 2024 donc 2005 il a quel âge Yanis 35
bah là je crois qu'il a 35 si vous
faites les calculs en plein de
d il avait 15 ans 15 anss donc tu rend
compes alors donc toi tu étais col ire
en fait non en fait petit am de la
colocataire de de de la c'était en fait
la propriétaire de l'appartement donc et
elle faisait une souslocation avec Bruno
qui était là mais Bruno tu le
connaissais il avait il faisait partie
de popstar à l'époque oui pas pas pas de
ma saison mais de la saison d'avant tu
le connaissais ou pas du tout je le
connaissais parce que je l'avais déjà
croisé sur les plateaux télé de
divertissement d' M6 donc il faisait les
il chorégraphiait les divertissements à
l'époque de de de la chaîne et et donc
voilà moi je l'ai rencontré et c'est
comme ça que j'ai rencontré ma petite
amie en fait et en fait la prière fois
que je rencont Marshall c'était entre
août et septembre
2005 et je suis dans cet appartement là
je dis tiens c'est marrant il y a un
jeune dans le salon c'est qui et donc ma
copine de l'époque me dit c'est Yanis tu
le présentes c'est vrai qu'il avait
était un peu foufou et je m'aperçois que
c'était le petit ami de
Bruno et donc à ce moment-là je me dis
ok bon c'est
cool il sa'est passé ce qui passéit ils
allaient au resto il ils avaient une
vraie relation amoureuse incroable et et
donc donc quand j'ai entendu l'histoire
de Yanis je me suis un petit peu
renseigné donc j'ai essayé de voir un
petit peu si tout concordait et quand
j'ai entendu l'avocat de de Bruno
vendelli dire que c'était en 2007 c'est
pas vrai en fait c c'était vraiment en
2005 et quand j'ai rencontré la première
fois Yanis c'était pas une romance qui
avait commencé à Paris elle avait
commencé auparavant en gros l'histoire
avait commencé à Cann euh d'après ce que
j'avais compris de ce que me disait ma
petite amie de l'époque elle me disait
écoute par contre il faudra être discret
sur euh sur le fait que Yanis soit là
parce qu'en fait il a pas vraiment droit
d'être ici euh parce qu'en fait la mère
de Yanis est contre cette relation
d'accord ah ouais donc voilà et il
revenait de il revenait à l'époque de de
Miami et euh je pense que c'est la merre
j'en suis même sûr c'est que c'est parce
que ma petite amie de l'époque m'avait
dit exactement ne dis rien faut que tu
sois vraiment discret là-dessus je me je
m'étais pas posé de question en fait je
à l'époque j'étais pas allé voir Yanis
pour lui dire dis-moi tu as quel âge
j'ai voilà je l'ai laissé vivre leur
histoire d'amour il avait l'air d'avoir
15 ans ou il paraissait non il avait une
petite moustache il était comme tous les
danseurs en fait ce qui est compliqué à
l'époque c'est je me vois mal aller voir
Bruno et dire dis-moi ton petit copain
il a quel âge là parce que ça me paraît
bizarre voilà et moi j'étais là j'étais
là occasionnellement en fait mais mais
toutes les fois où j étais il était là
quoi alors tu as eu Yanis ou pas j'ai eu
Yanis ouais tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que quand son avocat dit que il
avait rencontré qui qu'il avait qu'il
entretenait une relation en 2007 c'est
pas vrai il a rencontré Yanis à Cann moi
quand j'ai rencontré Yanis à Paris c'est
Bruno qui lui payit ses billets d'avion
donc il il venait par le par le billet
de de de Bruno il restait 3 qu jours à
la maison donc il se passait ce qui se
passait et c'était pas des relations
amicales donc on va pas se mentir c'est
pas il jouait pas au scraubble quoi
voilà tout simplement Bruno é é à Paris
lui oui pararis voilàoui et selon toi
combien d'années avant le le jour où tu
l'as vu ils avaient déjà une relation en
fait parce que ça ça se joue à à peu
mais là au regard de la loi s'il avait
15 ans il il avait quel âge quand tu l'
rencontrer alors moi je vais pas poser
la question de son âge hein parce que je
voulais pas meer dans l'istoire connais
la date et main
il avait 15 ans sauf que s'ils se sont
rencontrés 2 ans avant ses 15 ans ça
change au regard de la loi absolument
mais il se connaissait déjà avant
vraiment avant parce qu' fait est-ce que
la
relation moi c'est ce que moi de ce que
j'ai vu je vais être factuel moi j'ai vu
Yanis à l'appartement en 2005 d'accord
après ce que dit Yanis c'est qu'il a
rencontré Bruno à 13 ans qu'il était à
l'école à 14 ans et que sa première
relation sexuelle est arrivée selon le
reportage le jour de la fête des mères
donc en en 2000 en 2004 donc il avait 14
ans il avait 14 ans ouais c'est fou donc
voilà qu'est-ce que tu as dit Yanis tu
l'as eu ce weekend j'ai eu
Yanis il il comptait sur moi parce que
il en avait marre d'entendre les gens
dire que il avait besoin de lumière que
parce qu'il s'était fait virer de la
Stara il avait besoin de rester sous les
feux du des projecteurs mais en fait je
veux juste dire aux gens au haters qui
commence à lui tomber dessus Yanis avait
pas besoin de la starac avant il était
déjà connu nu il avait fait le tour du
monde et
que s'il fait ça maintenant c'est qu'il
en a besoin il a besoin de se
reconstruire aux États-Unis là il est en
Australie ah d'accord il est en
Australie et il donne des cours voilà
mais ça lui tenait à cœur de de de de de
crever l'absé on va dire voilà il avait
besoin d'en parler oui on va juste
rappeler que Bruno vandell est bien sûr
présumé innocent je d'accord avec toi
parce dit plein de chos je suis d'accord
avec toi voilà le tém ce qu'il est en
train de dire là c'est que pour lui ils
étaient qui pour toi ils étaient quoi
ils éta amoureux était quoi oui il y
avait il y avait il t'a dit quoi Yanis
moi Yanis il m'a dit à l'époque j'ai
j'étais amoureux de lui c'était mon
pigmon c'était mon mon père mon roi
sugard dit je sais pas c il a Mme dit
dans le reportage FM c'était mon Dieu
ouais c'était mon dieu il a il il a il a
dit dans le reportage que c'est son Dieu
et je le sentais hein il y avait une
espèce de de de de fascination sur sur
Bruno et et et c'est vrai que on peut
venir me dire mais pourquoi tu as pas
parlé à l'époque mais moi qui je suis
pour déjà les les autres n'ont pas parlé
ma petite amie de l'époque n'a pas parlé
les gens à Cann nonont pas parl moi je
je vais faire quoi je j'arrive dans
l'appartement je dis excuse-moi tu as
quel âge ok moi je trouve que c'est pas
normal je vais aller porter plainte non
je je les ai vu deux trois fois moi et
et et le truc qu' a c'est que quand ma
petite amie de l'époque me dit écoute
faut que tu sois vraiment discret ils
ont pas le droit d'être ensemble c'est
là que j'ai commencé à ticker et Yanis
me contacte au mois de ma mars de cette
année de l'année dernière voilà et il me
dit écoute faut qu'on parle et je me dis
mais Yanis il veut il veut me
parler mais de quoi en fait il va pas me
proposer une comédie musicale il va pas
de voilà c'est en mars voilà le 7 mars
elle me dit coucou toi faut absolument
qu'on parle appelle-moi quand quand tuas
un moment je me suis posé des questions
et il s'est avéré qu'il rechargeit des
témoignages pour pour justement
constituer
des pouruer justement con on connait les
profils des autres personnes est-ce que
toi il t'a dit peut-être l'âge qu'ils
avaient ou parce que quand même la
différence d'âge entre Yanis à l'époque
et et Bruno c'est ça qui qui est
choquant surtout en fait à l'époque si
je fais les calculs il avait 42 ans
ouais Yanis 15 ans voilà ça d'accord et
les autres profils tu sais qu bah
apparemment je je mets ça au
conditionnel je sais
pas alors y a eu il y aurait eu une
plainte auquelle d'ailleurs maître
cohenan a répondu en 2015 d'une mère
d'un très jeune adolescent voilà il faut
simplement rappeler cyil que pour le
moment les plaintes ne sont pas déposées
qu'il y aura évidemment des auditions
parce qu'il y a deux versions
contradictoires
té intéress d'avoir la vérité judiciire
mais pour le moment on est qu' début de
d'près ce qu' dit l'avocat de ce que dit
la justice il y aurait prescription dans
cette affaire donc est-ce que c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui se dit pu que est-ce
que c'est là non parce que si c'est
alors faut voir comment c'est qualifié
alors si c'est un viol sur un mineur de
15 ans il y aura pas de prescription si
c'est agression sexuelle ça peut se
discuter mais aujourd'hui les mineurs
sont extrêm protégé donc c'est pas du
tout sûr qu'il y a une prescription a
priori et bien évidemment c'est sûr que
si les plaintes sont reçues tout le
monde sera auditionné avec un mineur
c'est certain selon la loi l'âge de
consentement aux activités sexuelles
pour une jeune personne de 14 ou 15 ans
il ne peut consentir à des activités
sexuelles avec un partenaire dans la
mesure où le partenaire est de moins de
5 ans son aîné donc là ça ne rentre pas
dans dans ce cas de figure et et s'il
n'y a aucune relation de confiance
d'autorité ou de dépendance donc là en
l'occurrence ça rentre pas non plus c ça
c'est la loi qui a été amendée en 2018
la loi elle a été amendant
201 cétait justement pourriger cette
faille qui exist puis ce juque mais
avant la loi était tout autre donc non
seulement il n'y aura pas de délai de
aura pas de prescription et en plus de
ça un dossier si plainte il y a le
dossier sera réouvert et par ailleurs
s'il y a agression sexuelle le juge peut
très bien requalifier les fait ça peut
être plus grave en fonction des
auditions merci tu as autre chose à
ajouter merci en tout cas pour pour ton
témoignage